[Musique]
tv je veux votre sacrement fait pour
tirer au talent pratique sérieusement
comment vous vous mettez votre rendre
sur le manche comme sa maman sont si
puissants si fluide
pas tout à fait dans un monde idéal dans
un scénario idéal
il se fait à vide puis là c'est comme si
tu deviens vite que la musique
dans un monde idéal devient capable de
faire abstraction de toi et puis du pop
ça est votre seul c'est un grand talent
et mélodies puis ils sortent quand même
pas y penser ça ça n'arrive pas si
souvent que ceux-là des fois ci comme
des petits bouts comme sur ce que tout
ce que tu réussis à tence et puis
vraiment faire place à l'inspiration
bien d'autres fois on était tout le
temps en train de penser pilote c'est
une 500 à chaque fois que quand tu joues
pic tu pensé comme steam un filtre sait
capable d'y aller vraiment c'est ton
corps c'est le sas par spi ça peut avoir
l'air réseauter et coup mais je te le
dis que les gens s'en rendent compte
stevie vous avez quand même une arme de
destruction massive et génomique votre
pouce il est payé tu vas quand même cinq
fois les notes que personne dont je le
sais pas mais ça me permet quand même de
faire un pas qui la forcent souvent je
me sers de mon post faut beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de trucs joue pas de
pique donc ça me permet de me tondre
[Musique]
des fois je m'en sers pour faire
d'illusions mais il semble long et très
agile commence à payer
il ya ce qu'on appelle d'abord joynt
c'est comme ça chez nous à savoir 1
pouces comme ça sans commettre un nombre
de jours de congé avant des dépôts si
proportionnée ça s'arrête on la guitare
parce que ici comme souvent c'est à
l'extérieur beaucoup de confort comme
des accords et vous serez tous avec le
pouce comme un vrai que je vois comme ça
pour moi c'est naturel de 3,5
[Musique]
je suis votre carrière depuis vous au
tout début
tout a commencé pour vous à l'âge de 13
ans et là vous avez commencé à jouer
puis immédiatement c'est quand vous avez
senti que vous aviez un don
[Musique]
je me suis rendu compte au bout de texte
maintenant à 14,15 a que quand même si
on me le disait sans cesse évoluer vite
mon enfant puis à 16 heures jade mois à
15 ans j'avais mon premier tour sera
joué
[Musique]
puis à 18 ans je déménage à montréal qui
taxe professionnelle [ __ ] d'album
d'ouzbine pilotes et ça je faisais sans
quelques shows par année à partir de
deux stars jupe saint-james un artiste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez fait de nombreuses tournées
une carrière qui s'échelonne sur 30 ans
[Musique]
à quoi ressemble la vie de warcq star
steven moi je peux pas dire que je pose
ma corse très bas qui joue de la musique
dans même ma vie et est centrée sur mon
travail c'est clair en tournée et quand
j'aime cela tourner parce que j'ai j'ai
un horaire qui est toujours pareil d'une
routine que je trouve réconfortant
même si même si tu dors pas beaucoup de
travail tout le temps en tournée je me
lève le matin j'ai le temps des jeunes
est peut-être pour j'embarque dans
vannes ont fait de la route
j'arrive frais tests de son si j'ai le
temps de manger avant chômeurs âgés
après son fait chaud je rencontre les
gens retournent à l'hôtel la main je
répète la même affaire stimulant merci
mille fois ce que vous voulez c'est avec
un genre de solo diabolique
à bolbec
[Musique]
je